that's the thing with the LA Comics
nobody drinks they do a little bit of
drugs maybe hearing that but people are
don't drink they're about to Healthy
Living we're in New York you know Market
Sam they want to give you gout I
was like afraid to be more comfortable
with me yeah death there you go yeah see
you hear that market Sam you're making
people feel uncomfortable I get it those
New York podcasts I will even me they
are intimidating yeah it's also like a
different world you know it's like
they're more
um you know gonna hang on are you saying
what you're saying is it funny yes or is
it like are you getting away with hack
so if you say nothing right
then you go yeah you can't yeah and the
most they most that happens is you get
comments like this dude was boring and
I'm like sorry at least I didn't say I'm
hacked yeah yeah